they try to compute a function a giant
function of their inputs in an
interactive fashion and the quantity
that we're interested in is the number
of bits they exchange and you can take
that the parties have access to a public
atom tape and each of them have access
to fair fairness good and the inputs are
drawn from some distribution that is
known to both players beforehand okay
and I would like to associate a notion
of information cast to these protocols
and in this case I really want to you
know associate a number to each of the
players and want to look at them
differently for instance I want to say
that the amount of information that
Alice reveals in the protocol is exactly
equal to the mutual information between
her input and the message of the
protocol conditioned on Bob's input and
the public randomness in a similar
fashion you can talk about the amount of
information that Bob reveals and the
total information is the sum of these
two quantities but I want to look at
these quantity as I said you know it's
differently like okay not look at the
sum at one go good okay having defined
the model and the notion of information
I think we ready to state the question
so one natural question and a beautiful
question to ask is say given a protocol
with some information and communication
can you always simulate the protocol you
you know I mean can you come up with an
alternate photo call that simulates
original protocol with just other
information bits and say if you cannot
do that then the next question is what
is the best simulation that one can come
up with as a function of the
communication and the information of the
original protocol okay good and this
question has been well studied and BBC R
gives a compression to square root of
the product of the communication and the
information they give a simulation which
compresses a protocol to square root I
see bits of communication
and in the same paper they show another
compression for sorry
now the compression to ie times lock
square C where if they when the inputs
are drawn from no product distribution
and later Bremen drow showed another
compression to order of information plus
the number of rounds in the protocol and
this is a result that we use in one of
our compressions here part of the
compression and also Braverman gave
another compression which just depends
on the amount of you know information in
the original protocol which is namely to
to the other eye and recently g'kar
showed that this is tight and we did see
the separation in this workshop this
session essentially the exponential
separation paper it shows that true to
the order is tight and you cannot do any
better if you are just looking for a
compression just in terms of the
information of the original protocol
okay this does not rule out maybe
something like I times log CRI plus log
C or some you know dependence on
communication is the question still open
so so in this word we show two
compressions one where we get a
compression to order ia which is nothing
but the information revealed by Alice
plus C to the 3/4 times IB to the 1/4
okay and another simulation gives
compression to ia times two to the other
IP so earlier the other compression that
I mentioned was something like 2 to the
order I but here you know you were able
to get one of the terms outside like you
can suffer this but let's see where
these compressions are good or better
than the known previously known ones so
if you look if you look at the case
where the information revealed by Alice
is like really large and the information
if they will be Bob is like small
this case you get a compression that's
better than BBC are the good thing here
is like you're able to you know have a
difference on the information and it's
independent of the communication term
there so yeah and the second compression
actually says if one of the parties
reveals only constant amount of
information then you get optimal
compressions
something like to order I and in the
stock I'm just going to be I'll describe
the protocol or the simulation that
achieves the first compression so I I
won't be I won't have time to talk about
the second compression and as you'd have
seen we gain mileage when you know the
information is really isometric like one
party reveals a lot of information the
other party reveals very little
information that's a setting where you
know you gain some mileage okay and this
is something which you know we encounter
when we study data structures and let's
try to understand why that's the case
okay so we say okay the data structure
problem is as follows you have some
input and you are required to
pre-process the input and store it in a
very suction fashion at the same time
you want to retrieve data or you know
information from it in a very quick
fashion okay but an efficient fashion so
say you have a data base are you know
okay
okay so okay what's the problem so
you're given a query and the query
algorithm is going to probe some cells
in the memory for information and
ultimately it makes the queries and
would like to answer the question okay
so and every if you observe every query
algorithm now can be simulated by a
communication protocol where Alice
receives the query and Bob receives the
data structure okay and depending on the
parameters say something like the size
of the data structure and the cell size
of you know I'm one of bits that each
cell in the memory stores which we call
W here the word size the protocols are a
symmetric okay and an example quash a
problem that you know you encounter in
the are symmetric setting is this
question of lopsided said disjointness
where again Alice and Bob received two
sets and their goal is to find out if
the sets intersect but here you have you
impose the restriction on the size of
they said that Alice receives which is
here you set it to some parameter K and
the size of the universe is K times n
but you don't have any restrictions on a
side of the said that Bob receives and
an optimal lower bounds for this was
shown repertoire school and this problem
is very important in the data structure
regime because this was a central
problem which is reduced to many other
data structure problems and gave very
good lower bonds so I won't get into
that but I probably would spend more
time on the compression and yeah so
before we you know before I get show you
the compression let's just understand
this notion of the communication tree of
protocol so it's a rooted binary tree
where every node belongs to either Alice
or Bob
and fixing both their inputs and the
public randomness there's a distribution
that's induced on the leaves of the tree
and a particular run of the protocol
corresponds to a path from the root to
the leaf okay and every edge here that
have colored red is owned by Alice by
that I mean in the protocol this
particular message was sent by Alice and
everything that's colored purple here
belongs to Bob and to every node you can
associate a distribution which is the
probability of you know the next message
being sent conditioned on the previous
transcript and one of the party's inputs
and the publish animals let's let's keep
this we will probably use these
distributions or like the protocol
itself induces the distribution and
we'll use it later in analyzing some
parameters of the compression
so now I'm in a position to explain the
compression so let me first give you an
high-level picture of what's how the
compression is going to look and then
get to the details okay so I'm going to
do the compressions two stages in the
first stage I'm going to convert the
given protocol into a boundary run
protocol and the protocol is going to
look like this so okay before I describe
that the intuitions should be clear
let's take that Alice is the party who
you know learns less information or Bob
is the one who reveals very little
information in the protocol and so Alice
now tries to guess K bits of the
transcript and I'll make it very clear
as to what I mean by guess and so on but
and then she's gonna send this
transcript across to Bob and then Bob's
gonna verify if you know she's made any
mistake in the case or in one of the
messages that she has sent that
corresponds to Bob in the original
protocol and then he's going to point
out the mistake and Alice is going to
correct the mistake and then continue
with her guess and they're going to do
that until they hit a leaf of the
protocol and then so once you have a
bonad run protocol we are going to apply
this simulation from braveman rao which
tells us that if you have a protocol
with information I and number of rounds
being are you can compress it to our
simulated using order I plus our
communication and so for doing this we
need good upper bounds on the
information and the number of rounds of
you know the protocol or the bonnet run
protocol that I'm going to describe
but let me describe the protocol here no
let's fix a parameter K which I'll set
it later at the end but let that be the
number of bits sent by Alice in every
round and we're gonna use some extra
public randomness these numbers draw
between 0 & 1 so now starting from the
root alice is gonna guess a path of
length k but then i haven't told you how
she's going to sample this yet so let me
first tell you what these colors mean on
these edges so the red edges are the
ones that correspond to alice's message
in the original protocol and the LOA jiz
are the ones that correspond to bob's
message in the original protocol and all
these red edges are sampled privately as
she had done it in the original protocol
but now she's going to do something
different for these edges and for the
yellow edges she's going to use public
randomness and she's going to have a
guess on the probability that the
message is one condition on the on her
input and public understand the previous
messages and if Rho falls somewhere in
between 0 and this guess she's going to
send a 1 otherwise a 0 so in this case
she sends a 1 because no Rho false in
some range and she does it for you know
a rest of the protocol
sorry the rest of the edges and now
she's going to send this across and now
Bob has to verify if these yellow ideas
have been sampled correctly okay and he
has a disagreement if he would have
sampled the other edge like with every
node you associate two edges either a
message being a one or a zero so here in
this particular case Bob has a
disagreement because the probe according
to roof I mean using roof
or Hiro sampled a 1 instead of 0 in the
person for a cough ok and now he's going
to send the portion of the mistake
the first mistake she could have made
many mistakes but she's just gonna
identify the first mistake and say gonna
send the position across and Alice is
going to correct the bit and then go
down guess and other key bits and
they're gonna do that until they hit a
leaf so it's the protocol clear anything
so let's make this small observation so
a mistake is made when this number row
falls in between the actual probability
and the guessed probability so this was
the actual probability that no Bob
sending a message one condition on his
previous on the previous messages and
Alice's guesses so there's a mistake
exactly when row falls in between so
we'll use it later in the analysis but
we shall keep that in the background ok
good
so having described the protocol I am
left with three tasks or two tasks one I
have to show that the number of rounds
is bounded so I have to show that the
information is bounded okay the first
observation that you can make is the
expected number of rounds is upper
bounded by C over K plus the expected
number of mistakes here C I refer to the
communication of the original protocol
that's given to us and to observe this
every round in the protocol a that has a
mistake or has no mistake so you require
so C or K rounds to actually send all
the messages of the original protocol
and taking
every round with a mistake you know as
why'd you get an upper bound of C or K
plus expected number of mistakes so now
to pound the expected number of rounds I
just have to bound the expected number
of mistakes so to do that let's recall
that we had a mistake when the public
Adams I mean the numbers chosen publicly
ro fell mean falls in between the actual
probability and the guessed probability
so this tells you that the probability
of making a mistake at a portion I is
equal to the l1 distance between these
two distributions and Bipin square you
can show that it's upper bounded by the
square root of the information of the
ith bits in the original protocol and
now an application of cauchy-schwarz and
chain rules for you know mutual
information tells you that you have the
expected number of mistakes to be at
most square root of C times IB good
thing is you don't have dependence on ie
here something that you would expect
before doing the analysis
so I'm left with the task of burning the
information on this protocol let me
first do the easy part which that I'm
going to upper bound the information
that's learnt by Alice so every round
Bob speaks the portion of the mistake
which is exactly a lock a bit vector so
the information learned is at most log K
and therefore the total amount of
information learnt is locked K times the
expected number of rounds which is
quality
so now let's upper-bound the information
that bob learns is little tricky so
let's look at one single round of the
protocol for now and say the mistake was
made at some index J and so in the final
protocol or in the simulation we discard
all these messages that have occurred
after J okay
and these bits correspond to at most K
bits of information to Bob and now we're
left at the task of analyzing the amount
information that Bob learns in the
messages that are not discarded okay and
the messages that don't get discarded
you can be either if you look at each of
these messages each of these bits
they either correspond to Alice's
message in the original protocol or
Bob's message in the original protocol
so we can upper bound the information
that Bob learns from any message that
corresponds to Alice in the original
protocol by the information that he
learns in the given for a cause but now
it's we're not.we
but it's not clear if how much of
information that does Alice reveal about
the messages that she guesses right okay
so the question that we want to ask is
like that's the best bits guessed by
Alice you know reveal any extra
information to Bob and it looks like it
does and I'll use this tile Emma for the
analysis but I won't get into the proof
of this so what this is is
given a protocol in which Bob speaks one
bit with information Epsilon and you run
this guest protocol you will be able to
show that the amount of information that
Bob learns in this case is upper bounded
by the square root of epsilon so if
anybody tells you that each of these
bits revealed that most square root of
the information that Bob would have
revealed to Alice in that particular
step okay so using this lemma what he
can show is the information learnt by
Bob in the messages that know from the
messages that did not get thrown away is
upper bounded by ia
plus square root of I B times C it's a
log factor there I mean let me just okay
so I I a is exactly the contribution
from the messages that I mean the
contribution that comes from the
messages that correspond to you know
Alice's original message or message in
the original protocol and using this
lemma you again do and cauchy-schwarz
and chain rule for information to get
the square root CIB here and the lock C
is a technical issue so let's not get
into it and then for all the discarded
messages you know that information
learned by Bob is at most K times the
expected number of mistakes mr. see that
the total information learnt is upper
bounded by number
yeah I never died yes I'll show an
example
so before I show the example let's first
wrap it up and Wow you set K to be
something like C to the 1/4 and IB to
the 4 minus 1 first and you get that
your new simulation has number of rounds
bounded by C 2 3 first and ib ^ 1/4 and
some information actually you don't
really have to worry about all these
terms just worry about the ia and in
this tarou it's just nice by setting
care to be that number on these you just
get the values okay and now given this
you just apply the simulation from brain
and draw which gives you something like
order I plus R which is exactly this
number and he was you know chose in such
a way that the information and the
number of rounds are made equal
okay this completes the proof of
simulation now before I wrap up I'll
just show you an example where this
llamas tight so
Alice gets a number which is either half
minus epsilon or half plus Epsilon and
Bob gets a number which is either 1/2
minus 2 epsilon or 1/2 or 1/2 plus 2
Epsilon
and now let me describe a distribution
on both their inputs
alligator gets half minus epsilon or
half plus epsilon and pick one at random
with probability 1/2 and then after
fixing X Bob either gets 1/2 or 1/2 plus
2 epsilon essentially the numbers that
are epsilon away on the line and you
pick one at random from them and the
protocol is the following Bob sends zero
with probability y Y is the number from
between 0 & 1 in this particular
protocol Bob exactly reveals something
like order epsilon square bits of
information
now let's look at what the guest worker
called us so Alice so Alice his best
guess would be her input X and she's
going to have access to a public random
string I mean a numbered row sample
publicly and she's going to send a zero
if Rho falls in between 0 and X or she's
going to send a 1 otherwise and in this
case you want to show that they reveal
approximate something like order epsilon
bits of information that's because say Y
was half and if Rho falls somewhere in
between 1/2 minus epsilon and half
that's exactly the case where you know
Alice gets to know that XS X could not
have been 1/2 minus Epsilon that's like
one bit of information
so
so I'll just end by some open problems
so the first thing to understand would
be to see if you can actually compress
it to ifs C to the square root of
actually I see and I be this here we get
something like C to the 3/4 and IB to
the one first this would improve
parameters another very interesting
problem would be to see just you know
looking at the regime where IB is upper
bounded by log C can you compress it to
like ia plus poly log C or ia times poly
log C this would be very nice but
probably a first step would be to Allah
and we shows this and maybe not jump
directly to this yeah thank you
thank you